welcome back to unfiltered
cryptocurrencies got beat up this week
right more than a trillion of values
been wiped out in recent months critics
are saying a lot of this i told you so
stuff but is this the end of the crypto
craze here to weigh in as chief
economist at euro pacific peter schiff
and entrepreneur patrick bett david
peter you've been on the show before
about this topic been a tough couple
months for crypto is uh is this the end
or is it if we hit the bottom
well we definitely haven't hit the
bottom i kind of hope it's the end or at
least the beginning of the end before
more people have an opportunity to lose
more money in this pyramid scheme but
you know you talk about all the the
value that's evaporated it's just market
value there's no real value in bitcoin
or any of the other cryptocurrencies
they simply have a price and as long as
people are foolish enough to pay that
price uh you'll have market value but
the only reason people want any
cryptocurrencies is because they think
they're going to get rich they think
there's a greater fool out there that's
going to pay a higher price only only
they don't realize uh that they're
waiting for a fool and ultimately the
the fools that are left holding the bag
are you know are the losers and i think
unfortunately there's a lot of people
that are going to be bag holders in this
i think a lot of the original investors
the whales uh they've been dumping i
mean they pumped this thing up uh they
paid off all these celebrities and
athletes and politicians and they hyped
the hell out of it over the past year
they spent all sorts of money on
commercials and conferences and they
dumped out all this stuff to the public
and and they were cashing out and now
the bottom's dropping out of the market
and we have a long way to fall
patrick i'll let you respond your
thoughts on that
well listen this has got to be peter
fisher's favorite season because his
phrase moving forward for the next six
to 12 months gonna be i told you so
peter you ought to buy a shirt that says
i told you so and enjoy it for a year
maybe 18 24 months but i'll tell you a
couple of things here
the part we got to be thinking about is
peter may be right here here's the thing
when when disruption and change happens
we don't know who's right
there's a side where it's the way it's
always been done that's afraid of change
that's more of peter's camp which is
gold equities this is what we got to be
doing they have no clue what they're
doing it's a scam it's this they're just
trying to pump and dump you don't know
what we're doing okay fine he may be
right but he may also be wrong and then
there's the other side which the younger
generation is saying peter we just don't
like the way you've been doing things we
don't we just don't trust the fed we
would trust gold if our money was backed
by gold but it's not and your dream
of the government and our currency being
backed back by gold it's going to take a
lot of convincing and a lot of powerful
people to say yes for that to happen so
because of that peter we think you're a
little bit naive and you're oblivious to
what's taking place we want to take it
in a different direction because we no
longer trust the centralized monetary
system we want it to be decentralized
but i'm going to tell you this here
dan for us to be thinking about
no one is a hundred percent certain
who's going to be right it's going to
take about 12 to 24 months maybe 36 more
months for us to know whether peter's
camp is right or whether their camp is
right but if there's one thing that we
know
when you watch the younger generation
years ago when snapchat came out i
wasn't on snapchat i was on facebook and
instagram i'm in hawaii this girl named
phoebe's telling me let me teach you
about snapchat and i got on snapchat we
have to pay attention to what the youth
is saying because they just may be right
all right let me let peter i got about
just under a minute left i'm tight on
time your response to that well the
youth you know can be setting the trends
in music and fashion but you don't want
to take your investment advice through
them uh you know investment advice is
better taken from people who have been
around their season uh that they have
more experience and wisdom and look i
don't trust the central banks either and
if you if you like gold there's nothing
that says you can't have a
cryptocurrency backed by gold you marry
all of the positive aspects of a
cryptocurrency with the the benefits of
gold you have something that's stable
store value media of exchange unit of
account you don't have to reinvent the
wheel you just have to bring it into the
21st century uh with blockchain
that's an interesting idea guys
10 seconds just 10 seconds here 10
seconds i got it if he
10 seconds if it's about taking advice
from the wise we should take advice from
janet yellen and nancy pelosi and they
got it wrong so peter remember when you
were 20s and 30s these guys may be right
i gotta run guys i'm sorry great debate
i love having you on the show you two
are terrific thanks a lot
[Music]